salut sabrina m'a demandé de choisir un
objet parmi tous ces cadeaux pour
équiper ma nouvelle maison
vous voulez bien m'aider à choisir un
bon vous aussi là bas
venez m'aider à choisir mon nouveau
cadeau venez donner les enfants ouais on
va d casimir bien voilà je sais pas quoi
choisir les christophe bon laisse ton
bateau eric nous voilà si on s'installe
tiens si je prends ça c'est la casserole
de tout vêtement à quoi ça servirait à
quoi ça sert à passer par dessus
à quoi ça sert à quoi je sers la
casserole
ça sert à cuire les aliments et or là là
c'est difficile
si je prends ça d'en faire un plat
on va faire répondre christophe si
christophe leur permettrait pas beaucoup
un bon si je prends la lampe là c'est
stéphane qui le répondeur allumé ouais
ouais allumé co-animé quoi oui ouais
allumé quoi le soir chez toi conte du
travail
quand tu fais tes devoirs qu'elle chante
le soir ou la nuit le jour où elle m'a
dit mais la longue le jour le soir et
d'amour bon on se rétrécit j'en prends
ça là qu'est ce que ça te connais qui
vend déjà des châtaignes mais s'est
trouvé du bc saint jacques mais bon
comme on dirait qu'ils expliquent nous
saisit mire explique nous alors comme on
veut je ne fais jamais je ne sais pas je
sais pas quoi choisir
et qu'est-ce qu'il yad'autres là aussi
je prends la cafetière la salle louis de
nuit et les jolies un décideur mais
syrienne dans l'équipe
non non non non non ouais je sais pas
combien que dijon prend fin le 4 février
qu'est ce que c'est que ça dès que c'est
que ce bidule bon et l'hôtel le
téléphone là ce sera oui à ma à matante
ursule ouais c'est bien vous m'avez
rendu un très grand service je vous
remercie
chalon je vais prendre ça là la danse à
casimir caisse doit faire et que ce truc
là ça arrive mais parce que hein
un bon morceau de chambre à air avec de
la crème chantilly
c'est un de mes desserts waouh
catherine christoph stephan du nez bien
catherine bien voilà tessier côté de moi
christophe ici de l'oulle et stéphanie
see donc
tiens casimir vient avec lui mais on va
faire un jour chic art fair a jugé bon
tu écoutes presse christophe christophe
tu m'écoutes on va faire un jeu qui
s'appelle animal et machines c'est à
dire quand je dirais machine tant que
vous donniez le nom une machine quand je
dirais animal de nom d'un animal a fait
pas c'est compris c'est l'accès à ces
îles christophe si je dis machine est dû
répondre tu réponds du moteur oui mais
c'est pas exactement ça si je te dis
machine du dit un autre une auto un ok
alors comment c'est tranquille ici je
dis animal si je dis animal à catherine
attentes et en attend casimir si je dis
animal à catherine questions réponses
oui non
un pigeon voilà alors c'est parti
entendu à chacun son tour un bon on
commence par stéphane richard
machine tout comme en moto c'est ça
ouais catherine animal pigeon adieu déjà
dit tout à l'heure alors en août à nîmes
and animals strike on drague au bail ou
une quasi me renforcée par un dragon
fait bondir non post à casimir
maintenant machine un cheval à cheval à
bascule ses bons et ses mauvais à cheval
à battre
ces mauvais pourquoi ce mot veut
basculer
aujourd'hui que c'était mauvais bonds à
toi christophe
machine avions très bien machine encore
[Musique]
aller vite vite vite vite
la chine avait fuit fusée grâce à niall
gagner liot animal aller vite a souri
bon bah on va vous laisser et on va
continuer à jouer entre nous au revoir
au revoir au revoir
catherine animal